[Music]
6 24 on your mlk day monday you've got a
school zone flashing light
flashback now you may already know this
but from the emails i'm getting you
might be
more like maria or peter or jody who
write
why are ccsd school zone warning lights
working when students are doing distance
learning at home some of them are on
three or four times a day that was maria
peter writes hey we have four ccsd
schools that have them on even when
there are no kids or cars at the school
and then jody writes are drivers still
obligated to adhere to school's own
speed requirements if schools aren't in
session
well first for maria and peter dozens
and dozens of schools
all over town are being used but the
great folks at the cssd food services
department to distribute meals
especially since students are not doing
that in person learning and to keep
everybody as safe as possible the
flashing lights are activated
when anyone might be on or around the
campus meanwhile for jody yes
if the lights are flashing you have to
drop your speed limit to whatever the
sign says
violators are subject to the same fines
as if schools were in session
we have links to which schools are part
of the food distribution also private
schools may be in session
we even have the day-to-day menu options
on our website 8newsnow.com you just
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something's driving you
crazy email me traffic 8
8 news now dot com